you probably saw this already there is a
crazy viral video of a girl hitting a
guy and then a guy hitting a girl on the
New York City subway train
[Music]
[Applause]
so the guy in two others were charged
with misdemeanor assault after that and
the girl was charged with felony assault
for using a weapon her shoe in the
attack so alright guy should not hit
girl do I have to add more to that well
I just showed my son that video
yesterday saying look you know sometimes
some women will go crazy on you and no
matter what happens you can't hit a
woman so yeah absolutely you can't hit a
woman no matter what even if the woman
seems to deserve it because you're the
one that's going to get punished and I'm
glad to see that she got felony assault
because she used her high heel on him
yeah high heel will hurt oh he also was
a lot bigger than her right so if maybe
if he had been a little guy and then he
hit her that maybe I would feel slightly
different but the size of him alone you
can't do that yeah I mean I think I
think there are actually exceptions in
the case where you can hit a woman I
mean I think if you are an under
imminent threat bodily threat um the to
a greater degree of just someone
slapping you on the train if like I
think you get yourself out of the
situation as quickly as possible if that
means stepping aside or if that means
sort of backing off or if that means
shoving the person off of you physically
then you do it but in this case it
didn't seem entirely warranted for him
to slap her as hard she was laughing at
it's not a man should not hit a woman
but she was slapping the camera out of
the guy's hand she was Rijn no way about
it completely belligerent it was also
for I am on Saturday morning guarantee
not a single person on that train was
sober and then I think that you know you
you get riled up by the situation and
you could tell there were people fleeing
and there were people running there was
like very fight-or-flight happening in
that video from everyone on the train
and I I just think that it made a lot of
sense for all of them to get charged and
for her to be charged with a felony
assault but I heels it's just one of
these things where we have to accept
women get a longer leash because yes we
we cut that video we missed about 20
seconds up top it's unclear to me
whether he knew her or what started this
whole thing exactly but clearly we're
all granting her a longer leash because
she obviously was the instigator here
she hit first and yet we're all sort of
in agreement that he's sort of more
wrong it just doesn't even sound that
right to me what I'm saying
I think women have to have a longer
leash just so I just really think women
have to have a longer leash so that that
men can understand no matter what
happens you can't hit a woman that's
there's no other way around it you know
any me so what would you say that to all
the men because I know the comment
sections gonna light up and they're
gonna say ah these PC blah blah blah she
hit him first he has every right to do
it you can't hit anybody so what would
you say to those people because I know
they say if a woman is on the subway and
she's humiliating you she's probably
wearing Jessica Simpson pumps and they
won't have a problem taking it off to
beat your ass but if you're in a nice
place a woman's probably wearing
Alexander McQueen pumps and she's
probably not going to do that so it
depends on the pump
I feel me know what you think women are
shoes women love shoes and someone's
wearing a fancy shoe she's not gonna
beat on you with it yeah like yeah fine
hit the woman but now you have a
misdemeanor assault charge on your
record if you just sort of sat down and
didn't do anything or removed yourself
from it you wouldn't have that either I
think the way what he should have done
so again we don't know the full context
of this but should she have hit him and
then he should have just sort of sat
there in it and just jumped off the
subway at the next stop with that
assault charge then then do it but I
think that most people looking back on
that situation situation would've been
like I really didn't want an assault
charge on my record so maybe I would
have done this differently it's all sort
of like a 20/20 hindsight thing so what
do we say to girls right I'm guessing
she's about college age I mean what do
we say to them about yes there are
repercussions like I get it yes right in
junior high I think they should make
girls watch that video and say look a
man
is not allowed to hit you but you bear a
responsibility on your actions as well
yeah and what does that man supposed to
do he's in a subway he can't flee the
scene go to another car she's gonna that
kind of chick is gonna follow him yes
still because she feels its power to
humiliate a big guy like that that's a
powerful it's like a drug yeah well she
clearly was on a power trip there I mean
just the way she was speaking to him
even the face she made right before she
slapped him like you could see she was
like now I'm having my moment so if
you's a big dude about his jacket when
he's backed into a corner maybe maybe
some common sense all right final
thought on this um their other part of
the video that I think is really
interesting is all the taunting the
laughing the cameraman that's basically
doing play-by-play the guy that jumps
out right in front of the camera to
smile and laugh like what is it about
humans that we really do love this
like even when I saw that video for the
first time you get like a weird rush
from it like are we just like so we're
just repressing all our violent
craziness all the time that you see
something like that and you're able to
get it out I think you're absolutely
right about we repress so much of what
we want to do and when we see other
people behave like that it makes us
giddy like oh yeah we can see how that
goes down without having to participate
in it do you think people think that way
yeah there's a weird duality for me
because on the one hand I get so awkward
when there's confrontation and I just
like get complexities up and I don't
know what to do and I get really mad
that it's even happening around me
because of how bad I feel but on the
other hand I like I've always really
kind of wanted to know what it's like to
just punch someone as hard as we can
because I have dreams all the time where
I'm like swinging it can't actually land
a punch I don't know if I'd actually be
able to land a punch and it's something
I'd kind of like to figure out hopefully
I don't but like well this is just the
first segment we're doing here so maybe
you guys I think yeah cuz girl-on-girl
violence everyone's okay with that we
know that like anyway the moral of the
story is don't ride the F train at 4
a.m. in New York City and also don't
forget to subscribe it's right down
below
[Music]